عزل مجلس النواب الامريكي في سابقه
تاريخيه رئيسه كيفن ماكارتي لاغلبيه
اتهمته بالتسبب في فوضى وعقد اتفاق مثير
للجدل بشان الموازنه تجنبا للاغلاق
الحكومي وفي وقت يلف فيه الغبوظ الشخصيه
التي ستخلف مكارتي الذي اكد ان المجلس
يعيش انقسامات ومشاكل خطيره قال البيت
الابيض ان الرئيس بايدن يتطلع دائما للعمل
مع الحزبين
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم كان ذلك خبر حلقتنا ولنا في نقاش
ثلاثه مسارات
ما هي خلفيه واسباب نجاح مجلس النواب
الامريكي في عزل رئيسه كيفن باغلبيه اصوات
النواب الحاضرين وذلك في اول مره في تاريخ
المجلس والبلاد ثم كيف سيؤثر عزل رئيس
مجلس النواب على مواقف وخطط الحزبين
الجمهوري والديمقراطي في ظل ما يشهده
المجلس من انقسامات حتى بين الجمهوريين
انفسهم ثم منعكاسات المحتمله على اداء
المجلس وهل سينجح بانتخاب رئيس جديد له
خلاله فتره قصيره ثم نبحث في المقالات
مقالات الصراع السياسي في واشنطن وما حجم
تاثيره على مؤسسات البلاد وعلى السياسه
الخارجيه لاداره بايدن تجاه دول المنطقه
والعالم
[موسيقى]
حدث هو الاول من نوعه في تاريخ مجلس
النواب الامريكي الذي يمتد لمئتين واربعين
سنه رئيس المجلس الجمهوري كيفن ماكارتي
يعزل على خلفيه تعاونه مع الديمقراطيين في
التوصل الى اتفاق مؤقت بشان الاغلاق
الحكومي نواب جمهوريون قالوا انما كارثي
تسبب في شلل مجلس النواب ولم يكن صادقا مع
اي طرف وكان سيتسبب في مزيد من الفوضى لو
استمر اكثر في منصبه الديمقراطيون
استثمروا هذه التطورات حيث قال نواب بينهم
ان الحزب الجمهوري في موقف صعب بعد ان
اظهر انه غير قادر على الحكم لفتره طويله
البيت الابيض علق قائلا ان الرئيس بايدن
يتطلع للعمل مع الديمقراطيين والجمهوريين
على حد سواء بعد ان يختار مجلس النواب
رئيسا جديدا له وبينما يطرح الديمقراطيون
بديلا منهم لتولي المنصب قال رئيس مجلس
النواب المعزول كيفن مكارثي انه ليس نادما
على شيء بعد ان خاطر لاجل الشعب وابرم
اتفاقا مع الديمقراطيين كي تمضي الامه
الامريكيه قدما ما كان في اضاف ان هناك
انقساما حقيقيا ومشكله كبيره في مجلس
النواب الامريكي
[موسيقى]
لمناقشه هذا الموضوع معنا من واشنطن
المستشار السابق لشؤون الامن القومي
الامريكي ومدير مكتب السيناتور جو بايدن
عندما كان سيناتورا وكذلك معنا مارك فايفل
المخطط الاستراتيجي في الحزب الجمهوري
ومدير مكتبه الاتصالات السابق للرئيس
الاسبق جورج بوش الابن اهلا بكم ابدا بضيف
يا سيد ديفيد لمحاوله فهم الاسباب التي
دفعت بالديمقراطيين للتحالف مع اقصى
اليمين من الجمهوريين لعزل مكارثي تعاون
معهم من اجل عدم الوصول الى حاله الاغلاق
التام
في الحقيقه اعتقد اننا نتحدث هنا عن
مسالتين منفصلتين عن بعضهما البعض منذ 72
ساعه شارفت الحكومه الامريكيه على الاغلاق
تقريبا وذلك لان مجلس النواب وهو احدى
الغرفتين في الكونجرس الامريكي لم يتمكن
من التوصل الى اتفاق بشان تمويل الميزانيه
للسنه الماليه الجديده في الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه ولذلك ما قام به
الديمقراطيون انذاك مع
الرئيس السابق لمجلس النواب مكارتي هو
التحالف من اجل الحصول على ما يكفي من
اصوات وذلك بهدف تفادي اغلاق حكومي لفتره
مؤقته وهي 45 يوما من خلال تامين التمويل
اما بالنسبه الى ما حصل يوم امس الحزب
الديمقراطي لا يود ان يكون كفن ماكارتي
رئيسا لمجلس النواب لم يريد ذلك ابدا
ولماذا بالتالي يصوتون لشخص
يعارضهم بشكل اساسي
ويعارض مواقف الحزب الديمقراطي ويلقي
اللوم على الديمقراطيين كما فعل السيد
مكارتي يوم الاحد ويوم الاثنين قبل هذا
التصويت الاساسي ولذلك
سيعود الى موقف من الديمقراطيه لاتجاه
السيد ماكارتي شخصيا ام لحسابات تتعلق
بالديمقراطيين انفسهم
النار
ابدا ابدا لا نتحدث هنا عن مساله شخصيه او
هجوما شخصي حيث ان بذور هذا التهديم
والدمار لم تزرع من قبل
الديمقراطيين في الثالث من يناير مكارسي
هو الذي زرع هذه البذور تطلب خمسه عشر
صوتا على مستوى المجلس لكي يصل الى رئاسه
مجلس النواب وكان لديه عشره اشهر لكي ينسج
التحالفات من ضمن حزبه الجمهوري وايضا مع
الحزب الديمقراطي وفي خلال مساله او
المشكله المرتبطه بسقف الدين عمل مع البيت
الابيض ومع الديمقراطيين وبالنسبه الى
مساله الاغلاق الحكومي الامر سيان ولكن في
نهايه المطاف ان رئيس الصادق لمجلس الن
كان لديه الفرصه ولكنه فشل في سلسله من
المحاولات الاله الى الحكم من خلال مجلس
النواب عندما يكون جزء من الافريق من
الجمهوريين السبب الاساسي في عزل السيد
مكارثي الى اي مدى نحن امام انقسام خطير
في صفوف الجمهوريه
رئيس جديد ولا اعتقد ان اي شخص يتمنى ان
يصبح يشغل هذه الوظيفه ولكن سيد فايفل نحن
امام سابقه هي الاولى منذ تقريبا اكثر من
قرنين ونصف قرنين واربعه وثلاثين سنه هي
تاريخ مجلس النواب الامريكي وبالتالي اذا
كان فريق صغير هو الذي احدث كل هذه الضجه
هل معنى ذلك ان ايجاد بديل للسيد مكارتي
من صفوف الجمهوريين هو مساله سهله وستتم
في الايام القادمه
شخص يريد هذه الوظيفه لابد ان يحل الديه
قدره كبيره على التحمل ذلك المشكله هي ان
الجمهورين خسروا عده
انتخابات
الوسطيه قبل ذلك نصفيه عفوا ثم الرئاسيه
وخسر الكثير من عضويه في المجلس النواب
وبالتالي سئم والخساره وبدا يضع خطه للعب
والخطه للانتخابات للكسب نزيد المقاعد في
المجلس النواب بوفي ابن الشيوخ ولكن نتحدث
عن مجلس نواف حاليا هو كان يحتاجون تصويت
من الشعب لكن كان لديهم تصويت احتجاجي
داخليا وهذا اضعف قوتهم
فيما يتعلق بالسؤال الراهن الان بعد هذا
الحدث او هذه السابقه الاولى في تاريخ
مجلس النواب الامريكي الكوري يتساءل عن
شكل السيناريو القادم القابل
للتطبيق عن من سيخلف السيد بكارتي في هذا
المجلس وبص سيناريو المرتقب في ظل انها
المره الاولى التي تحدث
يعتقدوا انه في الفتره الراهنه نحن
بعد هذا القرار التاريخي لم يمضي اكثر من
24 ساعه اين هم اين هم
جمهوريون لقد غادروا
ولن يعودوا قبل يوم الاثنين اعتقد انهم
فوتوا الفرصه بالنسبه الى السيد الذي هو
الان الرئيس بالانابه لمجلس النواب كان
باستطاعته ان يجمع اعضاء الحزب الجمهوري
وكان ليقول نحن نفشل هناك فوضى عارمه هناك
تخبط ليس فقط مدمره للحكومه بل ايضا للحزب
الجمهوريه تعينوا علينا ان نعمل مع الجميع
في هذه القاعه الجمهوري كانوا غالبا تحت
نفس المظله بغض النظر عن مشاربهم المختلفه
كانوا يجتمعون في نهايه المطاف
الديمقراطيون لديهم الان فرصه حقيقيه من
اجل العمل على خططهم بهدوء بشكل هادئ نحن
لا نتحدث عن امر ايجابيا للديمقراطيين او
للبلاد حيث اننا في وضع لو حصل فيه هذا
الامر في اي دوله من الدول المتقدمه في
العالم الولايات المتحده الامريكيه يكون
لديها مشاغل مرتبطه بشرعيه الحكومه ولذلك
شركاء الولايات المتحده وحلفاء الولايات
المتحده وحتى الاعداء ينظرون واعتذر عن
المقاطعه ابقى معك فيما يتعلق بهذا المنصب
منصب رئيس مجلس النواب وهو المنصب الثالث
من حيث التراتبيه الاهميه في الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه بعد الرئيس ونائب
الرئيس ياتي منصب رئيس مجلس النواب تقول
هذه فرصه للديمقراطيين هل معنى ذلك بانه
هناك فرصه حقيقيه وكيف ان يكون رئيس مجلس
النواب ديمقراطيا ما التصور
لا اعتقد اننا سوف نصل الى وضع يكون فيه
حكيم جافريز وهو زعيم الاقليه
سوف يصبح رئيسا لمجلس النواب في هذه
المرحله لا اعتقد انه يحظى بما يكفي من
اصوات للوصول الى هذا المنصب ولكن حزب
الاقليه اي الحزب الديمقراطي مع نيته
بالفرصه التي لديه
الفرصه هي ان الحزب الديمقراطي يجب ان
يثبت لي الشعب الامريكي انه يعرف كيف يحكم
وانه يقول سوف نعبر هذه الازمه في مجلس
النواب ونمضي قدما وافضل السبل قدما في
خلال الايام الاثنين والاربعين المقبله
سته اسابيع يتعينوا على الديمقراطيين ان
يقولون نحن
الطرف الراشد هنا نحن نعرف كيفيه تسيير
الامور نود ان تصل الرواتب الى الموظفين
في الوقت المناسب الى اخره هذا ما تقريبا
فشل في القيام به الحزب الجمهوري في خلال
عطله نهايه الاسبوع الماضيه ويبدو ان
الفوضى والتخبط يعم في اوساط الحزب
الجمهوري لذلك يتعين على الحزب الديمقراطي
ان يعمل بكد من اجل التاكد من ان حزب
الاقليه
السيد في البيت يتعلق بتقييمك لوضعيه
الحزب الجمهوري فشل تخبط الى غير مستعمله
من مصطلحات وبالتالي ما السيناريو الاقرب
للتطبيق فيما يتعلق بهذا المنصب الحساس
وهذه الهيئه الهامه الهيئه التشريعيه
الاهم وهي مجلس النواب سيد فايفل
الجمهوريون ينبغي ان يوحدوا صفوفهم وتوصل
ما هي خطه اللعب ما هي استراتيجيتين هل
يمكن ان يضع شخص في موقع رئاسه المجلس
ويتعاون معه بحث لا يتكرر نفس السيناريو
مره ثانيه خلال فتره قصيره لان التوقيت
الان مناسب جدا للجمهوريين
ليقوموا بالسيطره على الرساله فلو نظرنا
ان الرئيس الحالي هو في
نسبه شعبيته منخفضه جدا في الاستطلاعات
حوالي 30 40
عنه غير راضينا عنه ما يتعلق بالجرائم
بالتضخم والنسب وبالتالي كل هذه القضايا
هي لصالح الجمهورين لكن ما هم مشغولون
بالخصامات الداخليه فيما بينهم والرئيس
الامريكي السابق في متهمه التزوير المالي
ومع ذلك ليس لديهم اي شخص او اي تنظيم
يركزون على خطتهم وقدرتهم على الحديث
بمعنى ان لا يحظى باي شعبيه الان هذه
المشكله هذا الشيء ينبغي ان يحلوه فورا
طيب باشارتك للرئيس بايدن كان قد صرح طبعا
في جديد تعليقاته على مشاهده مجلس النواب
من مستجدات قال انه انما حدث في مجلس
النواب فوضوي ويجب العمل على تجنب الاجواء
السلبيه في وهنا ابقى معك سيد فايفل فيما
يتعلق به الان ايضا لم تجبني ما السيناريو
الاقرب حتى يتم انتخاب او تعيين رئيس
لمجلس النواب ومن اي الفريقين وباي صيغه
الحقيقه نعم تحاول تصل الى ايجاد رئيس
المجلس ولمن الشخص يمكن ان يجمع الاطراف
المختلفه
المتحدثون والمحافظون لابد كل الاجنحه حزب
الجمهوريه ان يوحدوا الصفوف وهم ويقول
لدينا شهر سنه وثلاثه اشهر لننجح في
اللعبه كيف يمكن نوح الصفوفنا نمقر
الميزانيه للبيت لثبت اننا قاده جيدون نعم
يمكن نجد الكثير من المجالات الحكم ويمكن
ان نقوم نحقق بعض التنازلات ناخذها من
اداره
بعض الانتصارات حتى اذا لم يكن لنسيطر على
بيت الابيض او مجلس الشيوخ لابد ان نبين
بعض النشاط والحركه
ونجهز منصه لنا بحيث انه عندما يذهب النا
الا الانتخابات يقولون الجمهوريه الرائعين
وبالتالي لابد ان نعطيهم شيئا يرى انه
سلبيا فيما يجرح حاليا تحت رئاسه
الديمقراطيه سواء التضخم الاقتصاد
والتحديات كبيره
لندرس مثلا لماذا في حاله حرب مع اوكرانيا
ولماذا نحن نضع
نركز على القضايا الدوليه على هذه بدا
التركيز على علاقاتنا مع الصين الا يمكن
ان نفكر بهذه الامور الخارجيه بدا من
النظر الى الداخل وتدمير بعضنا الاخر الان
الجمهوريه الديمقراطي لا يفعلون ذلك السيد
بونجير
قال انه غيرنا على ما فعله وادى الى عزل
وقال انه انما فعله لاجل مصلحه البلاد
وهذا يدفعنا للتساؤل عن من سيجلس ويقود
مجلس النواب في المرحله القادمه بين
الالتزام لمطالب حزبه ايا كانت هذه
المطالب داخل حزبه وبين ان يقدمها ان يعمل
في قضايا معينه من اجل مصلحه البلاد ما
مدى خطوره هذه المساله سيد
الرئيس السابق
لمجلس النواب كفن ماكارتي ارتكب سلسله من
الاخطاء
الكبرى هو الان يقول انه غير نادم وانه
متصالح مع نفسه والخطوات التي قام بها
حسنا كفن كارثي ذهب الان وسوف نرى وجها
جديدا طبعا هو سوف يمثلون ناخبيه في
كاليفورنيا ولكنه تقريبا اصبح بالاخبار
القديمه الان اذا ما صح التعبير بالنسبه
الى الديمقراطيين يتعينوا عليهم ان
يتحاوروا للتواصل الى
التصويت
نتحدث عن الانتخابات الرئاسيه
نقطه مفصليه اساسيه يجب ان نتاكد من ان
الجميع سوف يتذكر ما حصل انذاك في اكتوبر
2023 لان السياسات المرتبطه
بالحملات الانتخابيه تقول لنا ان الناس
غالبا ما ينسوا ما حصل منذ ثلاثه عشر شهرا
اذا بالنسبه الى شخصيه الجمهوريه يجب ان
ننتظر لنرى الشخصيه على مستوى الحزب
الجمهوري هل سوف يكون هذا الشخص يركز على
مصالح الاقليه الحقيقيه في الحزب الجمهوري
غير المتعاونه والذين يودون ان يسجنوا
هنتر بايدن ويودون ان يتخلصوا من اي تقدم
اجراه الرئيس بايدن بالنسبه الى التغير
المناخي وتمويل لاوكرانيا الى اخره هذه هي
الامور الاساسيه الرئيس بايدن ادلى بتصريح
قال فيه انه على استعدادا للعمل مع
ما كان عليه ان يعمل مع جيم جوردن على
سبيل المثال كرئيس لمجلس النواب سوف يكون
ذلك صعبا للغايه ولكن باستطاعته القيام
بذلك هو الذي يشرف على جلسات الاستماع
التي تحاول ان تضع خلف القضبان هنتر بايدر
هذا هذا الصراع الى اي مدى سيؤثر على
مصالح البلد بدايه مصالحها الداخليه وكذلك
الخارجيه ذكرتما انت وضيف السيد بونجير
على سبيل المثال الحرب في اوكرانيا وهي
مساله مهمه جدا ومفصليه في الوصول الى
عازل السيد ماذا عن هذه الابعاد
يشتت الانتباه عن التحديات الجمهوريه التي
تواجه الولايات المتحده حاليا فنحن فعلا
في حاله جهد حربيا طويل المدى ضد روسيا
ونعلم ان الصين تتطلع بنشاط وتدرس ما نقوم
به ولا نقوم به ولانه لك
احتمال يسيطر على تايوان قيام بتصرفات
اخرى
عسكريا وسياسيا عندما كل دين هذه الحرب
الداخليه في احد جوانب الكونغرس الامريكيه
لابد ان نعرف ان العالم يتابعنا ويشاهدنا
عن كثبه ما نفعلهما لا نفعله هل نستطيع ان
نجمع هل نستطيع ان نكون الديمقراطيه ناجحه
ما يحتاج الاخوه قاده السياسيون هو ان
يدرسوا هذا الامر جيدا في الكونجرس
الامريكي ويقول كيف تبدو الامور لان
قويه
ولكن هذه وسوء الماضيه الولايات المتحده
لم تحظى بهذه البصمه القويه وهذه تامر
مثير للازعاج والارتباك يعني ما جرى بعزل
السيد وكما ذكرنا هو سابقا في تاريخ مجلس
النواب الامريكي ايضا يذكرنا باقتحام
الكونغرس قبل سنوات
اخذ رئيس دوله الى المحاكمه كالذي يجري مع
الرئيس ترامب الرئيس السابق ترامب محاولات
عزل الرئيس الحالي وانتهاء بما جرى في هذه
السابقه الاولى في تاريخ مجلس النواب
الامريكي ما الذي يجري في الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه
انا سعيد بانك طرحت هذا السؤال لانه هو
منذ ثلاث سنوات فقط تم اقتحام الكونغرس
الامريكي في سابقه تاريخيه لم تشهدها
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه من قبل نحن
نتحدث عن مساله مقلقه للغايه وكما سبق
واسلفت حلفاؤنا وخصومنا على السواء
واعدائنا كذلك ينظرون عن كسب بشان هذه
الامور ويرصدون ما يحصل وزاره الخارجيه
الامريكيه باضافه الى مجلس الامن القومي
يلعبان دورا اساسيا في حال حصل ذلك في اي
دوله متقدمه في العالم كانال يعبراء عن
مخاوف حقيقيه
شرعيه الحكم في تلك البلدان للاسف ادركنا
الوقت ضيفي السيد ديفيد مستشار السابق
لشؤون الامن القومي الامريكي شكرا لك
واعتذر منك وكذلك ضيف يا سيد
الاستراتيجي في الحزب الجمهوري المخطط
الاستراتيجي في الحزب الجمهوري
الى هنا تنتهي هذه الحلقه من برنامج باور
الخبر الى اللقاء باذن الله
[موسيقى]